an upper gastrointestinal endoscopy also
called esophageal gastroduodenoscopy
or egd is a procedure that allows
your doctor to see the mucous membrane of the
upper portion of your
gastrointestinal tract this includes your esophagus
your stomach and your
duodenum
upper endoscopy is used to
evaluate symptoms of abdominal pain
persistent upper nausea vomiting
bleeding or difficulty
swallowing it is able to accurately
detect inflammation infections tumors
ulcers and other problems possibly
present the procedure is performed
using an endoscope which is a
long thin flexible tube with a lamp
and a tiny video camera  at the tip
the camera transmits the image to a
monitor before the endoscopy a catheter
will be inserted and a painkiller and
sedative will be administered your
blood pressure pulse and oxygen level in
your blood will be monitored during the
procedure your doctor will apply a
spray to your throat  or will make you
gargle with a local anesthetic to
numb you will have to lie on
your left side and a support mouthpiece
will be placed in your mouth in some
cases you may receive
supplemental oxygen through a nasal cannula
uncomplicated upper endoscopies
take 10 to 20  minutes your doctor
will gently insert the endoscope
into your mouth and then slowly
carefully move it through your
esophagus until it reaches your stomach
and finally your duodenum you should not
feel any pain at this time your doctor may
periodically introduce some air
to  stretch the mucous membrane and
improve visibility if your doctor
wants to take a tissue sample he
may take one or more biopsies with the
endoscope for later examination a
biopsy helps distinguish
benign and
cancerous tissue it is also used to detect
helicobacter pylor the bacteria that  can
cause
ulcers your doctor may also use an
endoscope to treat problems such as a
bleeding ulcer or stretching a
stricture or narrowing of the esophagus or
stomach After the procedure you
will be monitored until the effects of the ulcer
wear off your throat may be
sore and a little swollen after the
procedure you will have to be accompanied
back
home